okay people joining this meeting this
is an incremental language development
meeting talking about
uh things to add to wolven language
and it looks like we have our main topic
here
is uh things that have been accumulated
in the function repository what can we
learn
for the core language but first
lexicographic order
yes a small thing we forgot to discuss
last week
which is is it psychographic or
lexicographical
i don't think it should be
lexicographical that just sounds like
some kind of victorian english
i see i never know over and done
i and if anybody strongly disagrees with
me
that say it but otherwise i think we
should i think mostly we agree most of
us
okay fine okay okay fine all right that
was easy
boom done okay next
hey listen i wanted to comment on
something about um
general utilities okay i noticed
somebody using there was some function
called something like print definition
from general utilities
which sounded rather horrifying to me to
what extent have we
gone through general utilities and and
uh
you know mined it for the function
repository or other things um
we okay i have two things to say to that
uh one is
we have gone through it i think fairly
extensively way back when we had
meetings
involving sushma and um others and we
marked functions
um to put in and and i think they've all
the ones we marked i think have gone in
the other thing is
as of today i saw in in a progress
report that somebody has taken on the
job of
migrating a lot of that stuff to startup
files which
i mean there's already system functions
in general utilities so
you know they're they're getting looked
at again i guess i'd say and also being
put into the right place
wait a minute so i'm confused here so
you're saying i mean they're like 200
functions in general utilities is that
right
some of them apparently are system
functions now
i see so they're being taken out of
general utilities
um the idea is to migrate as much of
that as possible to
startup files certainly
we're not using okay so hold on a second
if there's a function that is
incompatible between the system version
and the general utilities version
is that what you're addressing or or not
no um
i guess what i'm saying is we're going
to have some cleanup happening whereby
it becomes
more clear what is already built into
the system
in general util from general utilities i
don't think there's supposed to be any
incompatibilities
well well that might be i mean because
general utilities had a definite form
built you know five ten years ago and um
you know that might or might not be um
uh you know be something that um
we want to support in the system
right it has happened a few times that
we
constructed in system something based on
the functionality in general utilities
for example
recently echo timing and that created an
incompatibility and we had to remove the
function
in general utilities i see but
but maybe we should have a convention
for what to do in that case
for example in general utilities we
should leave something a stub there
that's called i mean it's obviously in a
different context
so it it isn't directly incompatible
right
it's not but depending on how you set up
your context path it may end up in
one or the other they will no i
understand it's a mess
yeah like shall we messages which are
annoying
so all right but should we not keep a
general utilities echo timing
that has been named i mean this is
something we're going to have
that's going to happen you know as we
promote these functions
from you know things like well from from
wfr
to the system we're going to end up with
incompatibilities yes
but but i think the thing the situation
is safer in the sense that
there will not be a mixture with respect
to context
no i understand i mean we knew that when
we built the function repository we knew
that that was an issue
i think what's being migrated if i'm not
mistaken
involves functions that are already in
system context so this may be a
non-issue
all right okay fine all right let let's
do a quick pause through these
already first question we we did put a
lot in
into the function repository things that
were not system functions
okay this pass let's go okay i i want to
do this i mean we've got how many
functions are there and but wait by the
way but why don't we have a
statement of how many functions are in
here we should have that now it's an
impressive number
is that what is it the ballpark of 2000
it's very impressive i mean you should
say that 1700 and i'm pretty sure it's
well more okay so so let's add something
on this on the function repository
homepage that says
a that thousand functions and growing
something like that
right um
okay all right so i think we need to
dispatch these fairly quickly
and i don't know where this list has
come from and how recent this list is
this list is old it came from a wfr team
review
we are going to we when we meet tomorrow
we will be discussing resuming these
reviews
okay hold for a bit
okay what and and we're going to be
going through them historically meaning
you know by date of publication
is that the right way to prioritize um
we okay yes and no we we
also did some that we had previously
marked uh
you know had had been brought to our
attention as priorities
then we started going through and we did
that batch and now we're going through
historically
um it's a it's a good order to go in to
catch up all right fine okay
all right so let's go through these and
maybe the approach we should take is to
kind of grade them
but then you know i think what we're
going to find is there will be a
small number where we say we really want
this
soon a whole bunch where they kind of
fit into a bigger pool
um
let's see ah santa says that 17. you can
do that
it's it's a difficult call i think for
us to make as to what we need
soon or want soon but
we can do some form of grading okay all
right fine well let's let's but
my question is what's going to be the
output from this conversation
i mean some of these things i mean look
birds say obviously in its raw
form it's not going to be a system
function you know
just never going to happen that way
however look at the notes though
this should be generalized to something
similar to speech bubble
makes sense it makes perfect sense yes
but how does that relate to call out
well one of the reasons we're having
this meeting is so that people like me
and jose can get a better idea of who to
send things like this to
okay fair enough so look here's what i
think we should be doing with this
call out is a function that is in you
know if i say list plot
of um you know table call out
uh i squared
comma i
um i goes to ten
oops i get that very fine thing
okay that is a proto bird so to speak
and i think call out just like labeled
right is supported
in this situation a b right and here i
could use instead of call out there i
could say labeled
okay i think we should have a call out
that is supported standalone like
labeled as supported standalone
am i making sense
um no pun but not my call
yes okay fair enough but the question of
what team that goes to
is i assume that goes to somebody
in in the front-end group because i
assume that's where label was
implemented but i'm not sure i mean that
that's also a
it's a typesetting construct right
it appears to be okay so i i recommend
that what this turns into
is generalizing call outs to uh
the naked case yes sandra is commenting
call out working graphics would also be
nice i fully agree
and i'm i'm pushing for that labeled
call-outs etc
um i think that's that's for brett okay
okay so do i need to make notes so how
how are we doing this because this is
the first time we're doing this
particular type of
review so i i'm going to who's who's
going to make sure that action is taken
on these things i don't want us to
do this and then then forget what was
done yeah i'm
i'm i'm taking notes and jotting down
all the items
okay so fine so then then the action
item here is
make call out work standalone okay and
that's the future of birds say
and no birds are involved no birds have
been harmed no birds have been
whatever fed it's not birds
okay onward block protected
the heck is this it's a function that um
if i remember correctly let me see
i see what it does this is internally a
form of this
um unprotected reprotects them before
the
i see it's a temporary unprotection
yeah blocked as it were
what is this i don't understand what's
happening here in this
in this example what is this this code
what the heck is this
why isn't that in an input line
this looks totally s messed up it's just
a cell to do
to set up the the function yeah but why
isn't it
it's not i mean this is a this is very
very confused
that's a separate issue it's a bug for
this and i'm kind of annoyed that we're
still not seeing the paran number here
but anyway okay
but but this does seem like a reasonable
thing to have
yeah i think we should just implement
this that might actually
be why we proposed it
perhaps well i i understand but so we're
green lighting it
okay unless nobody objects green
lighting actually implementing this
make sense this looks like it might be
an ild function
i think so okay
that's what i'm thinking okay anybody
anybody object to that seems like a
worthwhile thing to do i mean
my only question is whether
there is any extra tentacles here
for no i think this is probably
i'm just wondering about the i mean this
is in fact
block unprotected right
i was wondering exactly yeah so because
what this is doing is essentially
do not respect the protected
attribute right which is different from
well i mean okay when we say block
random
what that's doing is it's making a
i mean it's funny that the the name
block is obviously a pun it both blocks
stuff from the outside and it represents
a block of code
with certain behavior yeah it's an
interesting coincidence
i don't i know and honestly when i came
up with that name
back in you know whenever it was 1987 or
something
i i was thinking of it as a block of
code
yeah i still do um
but but i'm well aware of the other
meaning
well okay so look just for the sake of
getting through this it's we don't know
if it's blocked protected block
unprotected
um right
the uh
um by the way comment um
um uh some comments on livestream
muhammad
asks what will be the next version is it
is it um
uh we don't know what the next version
will be we're
we're hoping we we can get to an
interesting release for the next version
but we're
we're more keen on having see that there
it exists
there is you know there is a version
12.3 that exists
um but uh uh we're hoping we will be
able to justify it
uh we will sort of have all the all the
threads put together for an integer
release next
um and what will that be what's that and
what will it be
you mean what will the number be yes it
will be 13.
we're not going to skip a number we're
not going to do that because i prefer to
view it as sacrificing a version
sorry what do you
you know but the problem is you know we
got to deal with every culture right i
mean you know
we didn't avoid version 7 or whatever
right and and um
um i i was initially concerned about
that but i think it's
it's um it is yeah i think so
they um okay
uh comment from sandra about using
number of downloads as an indicator yeah
i mean downloads per unit time it would
be nice to get that data i mean clearly
the functions that are newer will have
been downloaded
see i don't know whether i don't think
functions have a spike from early
downloading
so probably it's just aggregate
downloading over time
divided by amount of time they've been
uh in the function repository might be a
good basis
for for sorting these things yeah that's
a good point
thanks sander um
okay let's uh another comment from
muhammad here there should be a general
expression domain function like
function domain that can
comb through an expression and deduce
its
domain
so in other words you're asking
yeah i'm i'm not as familiar with what
we've done there
um what's that i think this is function
type
i think this this is knowing the types
of the arguments taken by a function
that use the type of the combined
function
right so in other words it's using it's
using a mathematical analog of the
compilers
type technology right
don't we have that information
internally
we must have not necessarily
i mean you know there's so many um
functions that
can return
you know either number or some kind of
failure result
etc it's not i know i know i know i mean
this is the
this is the horror of types right is
that the fact is
that in the practical use of functions
there are exceptions
that often come in that completely blow
up your notion of types yeah you break
out of the type
system there's lots of uh good theory
about how to handle that but practice a
whole different matter
no but i mean that what's being asked
for here is
deduce its domain
i mean isn't that what this is doing
um i'm not quite sure i understand that
comment maybe it should be clarified
let's move on for right now okay color
to hex
that's not some kind of witch
type thing never mind
um it depends with this witch it it sort
of depends on how you
spell her yes it does
the very good danny
brilliant
brilliant
okay surely this is
part boy
that's an interesting piece of
functionality but i would have thought
that that should be in an export string
type form
i mean that feels like something that is
more like
um
i don't know it also reminds me of some
of the things we've done with with um
uh in code what what is it called um
bitin what is it called the thing that
gives base64 encoding and so on
right basin code i think it's called
one thing i will say about our general
process
here is if you can identify
you know we don't necessarily think that
these functions are ready to go
into system as they are yeah i
understand if you identify
the appropriate team to um send them to
we can do that and ask for
um comments explain what the purpose is
you know that we
well right i understand so i mean
essentially what we're doing here is
we're pooling these we're generalizing
them
um but we don't have to necessarily
generalize
you might want to just ask the
appropriate team to do that
we can if you want i'm just yeah i think
okay so what i'm
saying here is i think this is analogous
to basin code
somehow rgb color can do already the the
inverse
so perhaps some of the color function
can incorporate this right fine so that
then if you talk about team it's the
shoddy image processing team
but i i my comment is it might be
related to basin code
or it might be related to color convert
i'm not sure
probably more bass than code but um
sound is commenting that color convert
could
could do this i'm not sure well because
color convert
actually returns colors right now yeah i
don't see that as being quite
the same well i mean the possibility
would be to have a thing called color
string
that gives just like we have you know
integer string and things like that
um sandra is suggesting color convert to
hex
string i'm not sure well
we could have hex as an option no no i
understand but
right now look if you say color convert
this picture of a toy truck
to hex string what's it going to do make
ascii art um
good question right so i don't think
that's really right i think color string
might make more sense but there may be
other color strings that are relevant
for example we don't have a color name
function do we
this makes more sense this sounds like
it's the
reverse of sort of of a color name
function
no but it isn't because i mean if i say
look if i were to say color name
we do have a closest i don't think we
have it in names
but if we said just like we say integer
string
right and we get some
you know oh that's not what i mean i
mean integer name
and we'll get this right
um so i can imagine a color name
okay so i think there's a cluster of
things color string color
color name why is that useful well it
would certainly be useful for
you know if i be if i'm able to say you
know color name
of the red color right
then that's something potentially useful
anyway that's my suggestion i think it
should go to shawty's group and that's
what it should be combined with
we also have color entities so i think
to entity if you change color name to
to to entity that
it's not really very convincing
yeah but yes it would be nice if if
something can say oh this is
ocher or something yeah right i mean we
have that we
we've written we have a
a nearest function that does that or at
least i have had such a function if we
if we don't have that function
we have that function in water from
alpha
now that i think about it
um we have that and we also have that
going to paint colors right
and we also have that going to paint
mixtures in wolf and alpha those are
functions there
so i think this is the this is the
cluster that this needs to be connected
to
okay let's move on nested look up
this is somehow related to data set
you know stuff right isn't this
something you would want in a data set
isn't this i mean this object here
would be something that um
right so i mean if i took that object
and i made that into a data set
what is the difference between that i'm
i'm now confused what's the difference
between this
and the nested look up thing
is the issue that lookup is just not
general enough
right lookup is one-dimensional like
association
but dataset can do it you're right and
even with a single pair of rockets
yeah well i mean the issue is that the
syntax of lookup
we use the list here to get a list of
results
rather than a um
nesting yeah rather than a nesting
yeah this is like part versus extract
indeed
this doesn't seem critical the same by
the way the the nested lookup should
surely reference dataset on its page
oh yeah ethan is commenting the color
lookup could be an interpreter and i you
know i
i think we have this functionality i'm
so confused here
yeah i mean you're right that um
well i think look up i think we we
cooked our goose here with lookup
because we've used the
the list of keys as being giving a list
of results
um
that's an interesting point that ethan
is making okay
that is an interesting idea says
add defaults for when it doesn't find
the thing that is a that is a very
interesting idea so i mean the the
notion would be if you have an
expression and you ask for part five
right what if we had a um
you know just like we have up to you
know whatever it is right
what if we had you know um i mean this
is not the right name
if not found something like this that is
a very interesting idea that had not
occurred to me
that would be very useful so we have
discussed something like this in extract
not in part
in in part i find it more difficult in
strategies it's actually
in the third topic in the agenda oh
okay why is that difficult for pot
because part is our arc so so what
so in other words at that level if it
didn't find it at that level
fail in this way so i'm i'm saying you
know
let's say that it's you know let's call
it ifn if not
found so if i say if not found at level
two
give a if not found that level
sorry if if the if the element if
element two at level one is not found
this is actually a really good idea
which we should have thought of before
but i still don't i'm not sure so for
example imagine that we give
a at the second level what happens at
the
next level because a doesn't have three
elements hold on a second hold on a
second
what are you saying here um so imagine
that e
is is a just a symbol so it doesn't have
any
or or it's at least one
like this yeah so now it doesn't have an
element two so it will return a but
is that standing for the whole
part i understand what you're saying i
understand what you're saying so so the
question is we currently have an
identity
that this is the same as
ij right
and you're saying if we had a a fail
quickly um
it um
that that identity will be broken right
that's why this is more natural in
extract
which doesn't have a default element
either because extract
is a list of independent extractions
okay i'm not giving up on this i don't
think this is obviously not
doable here um
i mean i admit i don't really understand
the the significance of breaking that
identity
uh but i think there's a really
interesting idea this would be really
useful for lots of programming it's just
like you
you're going to do an index i mean right
now
with our new uh confirm and close
mechanism
what you would say is you know confirm
let's just say you were going to do um
but it's still it's it's a different
thing um
uh yeah by the way diff difficult
is um commenting on the maybe type in
haskell i think that our new confirm and
close mechanism
is a large part of that story
um uh
let's see
list a um
[Music]
oh i see what you're saying i see what
you're saying so
sandra is commenting that in this
example if it
if it if it if it returned
early here and never got to this piece
what if it returned the list a
right i would say actually
that it should follow the the stair of
if uh not and then return the last one
so in this case it in the first case it
cannot return
anything so it returns a and then it
goes to the next one and it tries to
extract the third element of a
it cannot so you don't speak oh i see
what you're saying
so in other words you're saying you
could nest it that's actually an
interesting idea
that this return value from the first if
not found
could be used by in other words that
this identity could be preserved
by essentially treating this yeah by by
essentially we compile this into this
and then any if not found is then
drilled again
exactly this seems more useful because
that sounds very good
this is a good idea i don't know what
the right name for it is
um absent
uh
um
if missing if absent
i mean the analog
right the more positive what's the
positive version of this this would be
if absent
whatever to me this is like a default
this is one of our default
value default part i see
maybe maybe
i really like this this is a great idea
thank you for suggesting that
um uh somebody by the way is typing
rather loudly
um right this is this is definitely
something we should
please please look at this let's talk
about this again
yep it's a really good idea i mean look
the general idea of symbolic rappers for
part is interesting because we could
also imagine a cyclic version of this
some kind of cyclic part thing which
i've also wanted many times
but honestly this is the most common
case you're gonna run over the end
you know what to do if you run over the
end
um yeah the defaults are
useful and in extract certainly i've
wanted it i do have an internal function
to do extract with the default
in part i haven't found the need so
frequently
i think it's just people use part
instead of extract just because they're
doing a very simple case
of a single list and so on but i think
you know the the um i mean look i also
want to put on the table the cyclic
idea um
i also can imagine in this case that you
might want to do something
different no no this this the only way
this can fail is if you're
um so go ahead
in my opinion with part one deals
typically with rectangular things or a
trusted
do you are trusting rectangularity with
extract
which is more useful for rugged things
is when you don't know exactly which
dimensions you are going to have in
this sub expression
yeah i understand i still think this is
useful i mean we could
have the same mechanism for extract and
for part
it could be i mean extract with two
levels of lists
incorporates part yeah i understand
all right anyway this is a really good
thing let's move on
um
yeah sandra's suggesting some words for
this i i don't think any of these are
quite right i
i feel like it will be nice to have a
positive word
rather than lacking missing whatever
um but i might be wrong
okay um
yeah um okay
let's move on here okay the wall from
mark
benchmarking tool you know i have to say
i think this is a function repository
special kind of thing i
i think this is a big messy animal and
um you know
should be probably uh gradually enhanced
we've got to worry about gpus we've got
to worry about this and that and the
other
i don't think this is a system function
fine there
if it is i mean it um yeah
we we we don't get insulted here i mean
we just see some we think of proposing
realizing some will get shot down
yeah i think this one is too messy but i
think it needs more work actually even
in the function repository
okay rarest oh boy
to go with communist yes
weird but not obviously stupid
no i think such things have their place
again not certain it belongs in system
context
but clearly has its uses
no i mean look one thing to understand
about the system context is if the name
if there's a good name that makes it
clear what it's going to do
then that increases the
you know the sensibleness of putting it
into the system context
if it's like somebody saw it and they'd
never know what the heck it does
then i mean i'm trying to think about
when that would be um
um right sanders comedy has used it to
check for outliers
yeah i agree yeah that's one
form of checking for outliers was
exactly what i was thinking
um
all right i i think we should consider
this yes i mean why don't we think it
through
and um um
you know i don't quite understand the
relationship between sort of the
quantilism
you know what i'm saying so so in a
sense communist
is not a quantile
story well what is it doing
it's i mean the question is if i wanted
to find
the elements that are in the top
quantile of frequency
the top you know um
decile of frequency for example how
would i do that
see what i'm saying it's like a scaled
version of um
of communist because i i can see wanting
to get
um
you know everything that occurs less
than one percent of the time
right
i mean this is the analog look we have a
ranked max
right yeah which i don't think i ever
use
and i don't remember how it works um
what the heck is that well i mean this
is um
i'm using the version from yesterday so
what is that that's really weird okay
nth largest element
okay
well anyway so my statement is let's
look at rarest
in the context of also you know ranked
max and quantile
make sense
some with um
let's say it
there's
possibly efficiency issues to be
considered
i i don't know we don't know i mean look
it's it's a design
look it requires some design thinking
which is going to take
you know we're not going to do it right
now but what i'm saying is
i don't think it's the highest priority
thing but i think it's interesting to be
able to get
look to be able to get things which
occur
infrequently in a list seems useful yeah
but the exact you know the things which
occur
specifically rarest maybe less useful
i i don't know i mean both things seem
useful both by rank
and by quantile so to speak um communist
allow for no
no i i not no it does not okay
i think i need to not run this version i
think this version is very broken
um
okay uh
no it doesn't it it's pretty non you
know
oh i see up to that
all right
yeah i mean yes one could
ask for a version that takes in addition
to n
maybe n in um braces or
m comma n or a scaled or something
scaled perhaps
that i don't know i'm not sure i mean
you're dealing with a discrete list of
things
i don't know how well that'll work but
but
i could yeah rarest could well i mean
let me just
just to be very extreme okay let's say
you want the first half of a list
right in our symbolic rappers world
we could imagine okay so this is an
extreme um
uh um
you know this is an extreme piece of
weirdness something like that
we have discussed these in relation to
take not to part
so i think a scale can be a take a speck
not a yeah i agree
but i mean it could be a part spec give
me the element
that is you know essentially at that
position
let's look at those that seems like a
worthwhile thing and i do think
that scale needs a bigger life i mean
it's it's i was kind of annoyed that
that i realized that you can't do
point and then a single scale here
and you should be able to do that
see what i'm saying i didn't know like
right but so i'm i'm suggesting that we
we allow scale in more places and these
are the two that i think
well the take is the most interesting
but even the part
seems worth considering i don't know
maybe when you get into nesting then
so what if you nested i mean it's just
says um
[Music]
yeah you can scale at each level it's
just not necessarily going to have a
clean meaning if the
thing is ragged but whatever
it it can yeah it can be computed i
don't understand at each level there is
a scale
yeah yeah yeah and i don't think it's
actually
likely ever to be useful beyond level
one
which argues that it's a bit unpart-like
but
why isn't it useful beyond level one i
mean you could have
the third element and then you want the
um
i can see that being useful if you're
trying to sample some big um
uh if it's a tensor yes
i mean if you know if it's not a ragged
array then yeah it could be useful
for sampling
yeah i think this makes sense at every
level
but i'm still thinking about the
discussion last time
for example we take specs it makes sense
to ask for zero
scale of zero it will be an empty list
but the scale of zero is that the first
element
well we have to define that i mean we
have to define what the i mean it's like
insert
you know insert could have could put
itself anywhere but we define it to be
i don't know what the floor and ceiling
concept for scale would be
i mean i agree that look look the
obvious thing to do
it's like it's like list step plot or
any of these other things which go which
have to define
where they go where the step goes
relative to you know is it a floor is it
a ceiling
so my guess is that the right definition
is that it is the ceiling
of the you know that that basically what
it is is it's the ceiling of the scaled
parameter
it's the part of the ceiling of the
scaled parameter
with my guess so so for zero
well i don't know what i'm talking about
there for zero
yeah i it requires more thought i mean
that that would be
oh boy it's kind of like
plus epsilon and then you take the
ceiling
i'm not sure i i don't think this is a
crazy idea but
let's move on okay okay next we have
dynamic map and ethan is commenting
that his favorite function repository
functions of github installed
like i really want to see dynamic map i
really want to see this work
and and for me you know whenever i use
a parallel map i always use parallel map
monitored from the function repository
not parallel map itself
i mean that that is just so incredibly
useful
that um
yeah we're we're putting these all
together in the category
uh for the there's a project underway i
believe
to do show progress uniformly and
that's where we have these in mind
all right not necessarily to be taken as
they are but to be considered
well i think that yes i mean look
basically this project needs to be
i don't know you know i'm not sure it's
an ild
project exactly but it's part of the
progress monitoring
project right where is that being done
what group is doing that
lcc i'm i have a meeting with utah
tomorrow we're going to discuss bringing
it back up
in a future meeting okay fine because
that that's where this should be
i mean we need dynamic monitoring for
all these functions
and um uh
yes so so okay so ethan is commenting on
the fact that dynamic map collects and
saves partially completed work on abort
that's another separate issue so one is
monitoring the other is the ability to
do
uh you know partial results
yeah partial results i think is more
complicated than monitoring
but it's certainly something we should
look at
okay let's let's move on inflection
points i haven't
don't didn't we okay i have no opinion
about this the calculus team should
opine on this i don't know
they did opine on it that's how it
that's how it got into here
and they said what they they thought
that this was worth promoting the
ild side of the scale thought it was
idiotic
to put this in we need to hear from
somebody in the calculus team i don't i
just i know
yeah that's fine with me same idea i
just don't know i it seems like these
are
look these both seem to me if they're
well-defined they're well-defined
pieces of functionality i don't see why
we wouldn't have them in
but i don't know if they're not
well-defined and by the way look at that
bug there
um if they're not well-defined or they
have all kinds of other tentacles then
it's a different story
i think hessian determinant is
definitely something though that um
devendra might want to consider whereas
inflection points i don't really know
who would get that
or you know for putting it into system
function i just don't know
i think it's defender again it is
because yes so an an
atom i think it's complicated though i
mean i i predict this is going to get
complicated
i think hessian determine is very well
defined and we just
do it um
okay but i think inflection points i am
nervous that it will get complicated
because you know for example inflection
points of a non-univariate function who
knows what that means right
so you know i think that's a that's a
thing to to do um
seth is saying the keyboard shortcut for
resource function did we put that in
i didn't know we put that in i wanted
that what is the keyboard shortcut
that's a big silence
guys do we have do we put that in i knew
i knew i wanted something like that but
i didn't think we put it in
anybody about these keyboards uh
circuits
i should find out maybe seth can say
what what
what it is and tell us
every key you can think of and an r
well nothing's working for me okay um
shift option how can you even press
those three
shift option apple ah that's a really
weird chord
no that's something completely different
god knows what that brought up
hmm okay well that's a question for the
that's for tea user assistance we had
talked about putting in something like
this but i didn't think we did it
um okay can we get that found out please
yeah yeah i can check
resource function input
i am embarrassed to not know this i mean
i wanted this i didn't think we got it
in
and if it isn't in it's something for
the user assistance meeting
oh insert resource function okay
i don't know this
i'm very confused here
[Music]
oh
that makes sense but that's interesting
in in um
okay that explains it i hadn't installed
it
but yeah the idea does this work i mean
the idea of having
a i mean we've talked about having a
keyboard shortcut for this
um
escape rfi escape okay let's put this in
the user assistance meeting please
talking about a shortcut for function
repository i think it's more likely
something more like control equals
um but then you know then the trick is
to get the autocompleter to work
on that um which is now working i
believe if you type in resource function
i believe that this is now working
birds say why is that that's a stupid
set of
of pure defaults there that's crazy
guys i think that shouldn't be there
on on single quote that shouldn't be
there
make sense can we remove that please
hello devon
uh yeah yeah i got a screenshot
okay
and i don't understand why this is this
this looks
that like badly ranked stuff here
i'm not seeing i mean the bird say i
think it's just amusing but but i don't
know why
um this um
is there really a reason to have
anything come up with when there's fewer
than two
full characters typed for the name
probably not we've got enough things
here that i don't think it makes a lot
of sense
yeah i mean i don't you know i don't
know about
x well
i think it it you know it's a standard
you know standard issue that we've
we've have for the um for system
functions as well
um i mean yeah one could imagine a
heuristic
if there's more than 20 with that prefix
then yeah yeah yeah that there are such
heuristics they've
this this is a problem that has already
been solved
but in a in the different context of
pure system functions
okay so is it the same people person
whatever who works on that working on
yes yes it's i mean this should this is
part of user assistance
okay that's where that goes um but i
mean i think specifically
the um uh there was an issue which i
think i
resolved of of getting the data from the
function repository
into the packet that does
this local auto completion i believe
that problem is solved so there should
be no further excuses there
okay comments from
um
muhammad about uh be nice if you could
replace c by using a high-level language
or language with a compiler yes we are
aware of this
actually christopher has a project right
now to basically
uh design a better version of the
intermediate language that allows for
immediate compilation
initially that intermediate language
will not contain
well you know it'll it'll require lower
level specifications than
than ordinary wolf and language stuff
but gradually over time but it will but
it will work
perfectly so to speak and gradually over
time it will allow more and more
automation
so that's that's kind of the direction
and to be able for us
and and serious developers to be able to
write code
that uses all of the these you know data
structures that
that are associated with the compiler
and so on in a nice way
and now if anybody wants to have that
happen more quickly
send mail to christopher and tell them
to work on this
um okay
let's see um
uh comments here
i see i see the point muhammad is making
this point
that um this doesn't work
oh that's but i don't understand whether
that's a bug or whether that's a
okay please report that that goes to the
atom
i think devon please yep i got it
okay um multiple access list plot
that is a priority for brett uh i don't
think it needs to be i mean the fact
that we have
something working in the function
repository is good but i believe that's
part of brett's
roadmap for the next version please
check
okay i mean maybe the right thing to do
is just make him aware that this exists
in case he wants to
well yeah absolutely break parts
absolutely absolutely
okay
um
i don't know i mean we've had things
like this
before i feel like i'm not convinced
about this
um i mean look
there's a revamp of the statistics
functionality and all the crazy anova
stuff and things like this
that's coming and this probably would
fit into that this would go to the
statistics team to gosha
and so on right
makes sense yeah okay
and and by the way a comment for that i
i don't know what the current roadmap is
for updating things like anova and so on
which should be using modern data set
functionality
and as i say this might fit right into
that
unclear to me
let's go okay
i see muhammad is commenting that
expression domain could generalize
function domain
i i'm confused by what that means
because i think
in other words a a predicate that
returns true or false also
has a domain over which
that predicate has a definite value and
i'm not sure how that should relate to
what we mean by function domain
um
solar system plot 3d
i think this can be considered part of
the astro work
yeah this is part of astro graphics
empty queue
i don't know maybe
this will be difficult unless it's
something as trivial as length zero
it's quite difficult to define what
empty yeah i i don't think this is a
i'm not i'm not convinced about this
right now
stationary points that's like inflection
points i have no opinion it should be it
should be looked at in the same way
this one might be more easily defined
it's sort of
clear what the generalization is to
multiple dimensions
right not saying we need to have it just
that it
it it will be less of a headache look i
think the issue here is
we've got a whole gaggle of functions
that have to do with optimization
minimization maximization and so on
right
and i mean curiously
you know most okay
so most of the time people say i want a
maximum i want a minimum if you're if
you're ordering
um uh you know shelving units or
something that's what you want
in physics sometimes one deals with
extrema
that are not necessarily maximum or you
know you don't know if it's a maximum
minimum that's an unusual case
i mean i don't know other than for
educational purp well i guess in physics
the stationary points thing comes up
um i think i think there's a conflict
here because we've got a lot of things
which are for practical you know
linear programming style optimization
where maxima or minima are really
distinguished
this is a place where it's extrema that
are being put together
am i or did i like what's that not just
extrema but this would include all of
them yes for a smooth function
right well i understand right it could
be local
maxima or minima it could in multiple
variables or whatever
it it it doesn't even have to be i mean
think of
right y equals xq you know yeah this
does make some sense because this is
cleaner than you know
messing around solving the you know
derivatives equal to zero and so on it's
much messier than this
and i can imagine this seems like a
sensible one
this is for adam and so on but it seems
sensible to me
okay this is something that would be
quite useful to have
because right now
i mean like let's say you're making a
table and you want to make a table over
this is probably something that was
cribbed from alpha where it has lived
for well over a decade
well i know i agree it's useful
right the the predictive interface for
example has been using this for a long
time
yeah yeah it's just a way of exposing it
another way right and the question is in
in the you know if i say
plot and i just say you know should we
in fact support at some point
a pure plot sine x comma x
that would be very nice i think i think
so too
i i don't see why we shouldn't support
this i mean we've it's been well tested
in alpha now and yeah there are cases
where it will fail
but then if it fails then give a plot
range
but you you still would want this
function
to exist independently i think i think
so too
yeah it's like it's like the thing that
gives um
what is the function that gives you tick
values what is that called
fine division what's that find divisions
yeah
find divisions
i mean this is probably a find type
function
um what should it be called
i'm not sure what it should be called
but i think this function is a good idea
and i think we should talk about this
and that's a brett
story to talk about that possibility i i
believe both this function and that
possibility go to that group or am i
mistaken uh this function is a
is a michael project production isn't it
i think so the one we are using the
predictive interface comes from michael
i don't know who wrote this one
it could be his yeah i think i mean it's
it's a michael kind of project
are you i i had thought many years ago
that it was sam blake who worked on that
code
but it could be that could be before he
solved the zodiac thing recently yeah
yeah the damn what's that
is it go sam yeah yeah it's impressive
the um
um
let's see uh i don't know an obvious
name
and i don't know i mean and it's not
obvious to me i mean
it's basically a function
suggested function range or something
it's hard to know what you're suggesting
it for i mean it's it's basically
um
i mean i could imagine a second argument
that you know it's like
where do you want it plotted i think in
alpha we we have two different ranges
that we typically show
anyway i think we should i think this is
something for michael but i think you
know the main discussion is going to be
what the detailed functional design is
i think it's something like a find
relevant training to find something
range
yeah i agree but i don't know whether
it's fine function range
we don't have a function we have
function domain
i don't think you want to call it find
function range
it sounds too much like you're giving
the full range
i see one reason i like suggest plot
range find plot range might be okay
um when you say it's a plot
it's sort of implied that this is a more
heuristic type of thing
yeah i understand better function range
okay let's just try and get through a
couple more of these and then we should
wrap here
this is a good process this is useful
look nth digit i kind of think we should
just have it
i mean i'm not sure if that's exactly
the right name but well
or does real digits give does real
digits allow you to specify a single
digit
i don't think so i don't think integer
digits does either
no i don't think so so we could easily
do that
unless this is
i i think we should examine the
possibility that real digits and integer
digits
should be allowed to specify a window
effectively
rather than a you know a range starting
at the beginning or
whatever well it looks like the four
argument type might be that window
if the you know
yeah i mean the issue with nth digit is
you know from which way round like for
for an
integer the
you know it's much more likely to be the
digits from the end than the digits from
the beginning that you care about
i i mean
i mean i can imagine something that is
more like digit take
i'm not sure this requires more design
but i think that one is one
worth exploring
that um seems like that might be for us
i'll do i think so i think that's an ild
thing okay
didn't we evaluation timing isn't that
isn't that something we already
could be similar to echo timing or i
would think so
this might yeah this might be superseded
by
no no this is much fancier it's a
profiling function
[Music]
oh
drag zoom plot
uh i think that's being worked on by
brett
so you know let him be aware that the
that we have this in case it's of
interest well yeah
definitely right definitely
this should just become an import format
yeah that's right that's what our
comment is
except it's just not totally obvious
what the output form should be
right because i mean we don't have a
symbolic chess representation that we
can do anything with
like for example i don't think we have
functions do we have functions in the
function repository that
that represent a a valid uh chess move
and things
um for example given a given a board
position
can we get a list of valid moves i have
no idea
well that's the question to ask because
that's what we would need to fit it into
something useful
what import pgn
yeah because i mean well whatever format
it gives
okay so look if we standardize on a
symbolic representation of chess
then you know we can expect to build
functions in the function repository
that do things like
you know what are the valid moves what
are the highest ranked moves et cetera
et cetera et cetera
sandra is suggesting that we generalize
palindrome queue to work with any
base does it not work with any base
right now it's kind of crazy
no it does that's a good suggestion
wow what is integer reverse doesn't
integer reverse that must have a base it
cannot possibly not have a base
be crazy to not have a base
yes fine okay so the the idea is just to
have palindrome
have a base for when it's in a case that
seems like an obvious thing to do
that also us yes all right this is a
good process we need to go on with it
um
yeah in this second group we have
grouped the related functions
files strings etc okay ali is asking
why notebooks are slower and slower with
more graphics
um okay i think there is a very specific
issue which i have run into
which has to do with graph objects
that have dynamic locators in them that
come from graph objects with performance
arrow quality
this is a horrifying thing that has
bitten me recently
and it's being fixed um
multiple
i'm not sure i'll in in response to ally
here
um about multiple 3d graphic objects
size of notebook increases notebook gets
stuck
i don't know i don't know be great if
you sent us examples of this
um
seth is commenting on causal inference
and graphical models and all those kinds
of things yes
we have thought about this for multiple
years and it has been in our plans
um and i i think we are surely getting
closer to it
um i think it may be
uh one of the next things after spatial
statistics we still have another
round of stuff to do with spatial
statistics but i think that's uh
certainly something we're aware of um
i'm not certain you know there's
questions about
um um
the representation of graphical models
which maybe there's an obvious symbolic
representation of them
that would be an interesting thing to
explore and maybe we should get some
function repository functions for
graphical models
before we really dig into to colonizing
them
um and uh
gustavo is asking is there a benchmark
function for the front end
oh boy uh
yeah well good question i mean it's a
very non-trivial thing to see
i mean even even when we do one's
dealing with the web we have web execute
and we have the ability to kind of
monitor
what's happening in a web browser but in
the case of um
um the uh the front end it's it's just
hard to know what's
i mean i i think we have a bunch of
tools in our qa
area for doing this but i don't think
they're tools that are
uh you know i think you have to go out
to the operating system to know what's
actually happening what the what the
person is seeing on the screen
i don't know um i mean i think the
things that we have that do notebook
insertion and so on
i don't think they really tell you what
actually happened
in um uh you know and and final
rendering on the screen
i'm not sure though it's a good question
all right i think we should wrap up here
for now um
and uh look forward to continuing this
this is
i think there's a really good process
i'd i just like to get some sense of our
1700 functions here
you know how many we think we're going
to want to go over in this way
it's a good question my hope
was that we would winnow down to maybe
20 percent
uh for you know suggesting for further
consideration but we did not achieve
that it was somewhat higher
underfoot i think they're going to be
categories like this one where they're
uh um
significant um um you know where there's
a significant number that that are
interesting
and other ones where they're many fewer
well
yeah anyway it'll it'll be a process
and right but and then we have to figure
out exactly what we do with the function
that was in the function repository
that gets promoted and how that all
works but we'll get to that
all right i'm supposed to remind people
i'm doing
another live stream a new series about
business and innovation q a for young
entrepreneurs
and others that starts in about half an
hour and i need to have some lunch
before then um as well as doing another
meeting
so um uh
well thanks everybody in this meeting
and thanks to folks on the live stream
for joining us
and